everyone knows Sony's PlayStation Vita
their powerful little handheld device
well as of last week in North America
everyone can now buy a PlayStation TV
which is essentially a PlayStation Vita
in this compact format without a screen
or controls essentially you hook it up
to your television and you can sync it
up with a DualShock 3 or a Dualshock 4
play video games PSP games PSone
classics but you can also stream video
from your Playstation 4 in one room to a
Playstation TV in another room now those
are a lot of promising features but the
real question is how well does it work
it turns out nearly every aspect of the
PlayStation TV has limitations that may
catch you off guard it's not that the
PlayStation TV doesn't do it it claims
but it doesn't do it as well as you
expect first and foremost the
PlayStation TV is ostensibly a vita
that's traded in its battery display
touch capabilities and controls for HDMI
and wireless controller connectivity it
still utilizes Vita cartridges and
memory cards and thankfully existing
Vita owners can move their memory card
to the PlayStation TV and retain all of
their installed apps and games it
outputs video over HDMI at 480p 720p and
1080i and if you crave faster than
wireless Internet connectivity
there's an Ethernet port at the ready
when it comes to game support there's a
decent selection of Vita games that work
flawlessly but obviously without support
for true touch-based controls there are
limitations it's not all bad
Sony implemented a fair solution for
dealing with slower paced games that use
touch controls from menus and things
like that when playing video games with
either of the supported controllers be
it a dual shock 3 or 4 l3 or r3 will
activate a cursor that can be controlled
with the corresponding analog stick and
shoulder buttons the system works as
intended but it's cumbersome at best and
alas the DualShock 4's touchpad is left
unused of course not every Vita game
relies on touch controls so it's not
totally damming that the PS TV isn't
mature enough to account for those
titles there are currently over 140 Vita
games that are supported
not counting PSP PSone classics
PlayStation minis and PlayStation mobile
games if you count those libraries then
the number adds up to roughly 7 played
games currently compatibility is
dictated by a whitelist that's defined
by Sony which means that future titles
retail or downloadable may not be
supported without
firmware update also just because a game
doesn't rely on touch controls such as
Metal Gear Solid HD collection there's
still a chance that it won't work on the
PlayStation TV given the discrepancy in
controls is understandable why not all
Vita games might work but it's not
immediately clear why there isn't
support for the entire library of
downloadable PSone classics and PSP
games both of these supported
controllers have the necessary inputs
some games that work in the Vita like
the PSP game Castlevania the Dracula X
Chronicles just aren't supported
hopefully Sony can patch these gaps in
support in the near future when it comes
to support for non gaming apps there's
one app that isn't supported by the
PlayStation TV which absolutely should
be netflix even if you've never use the
app on your Vita if you have a
PlayStation TV connected to your monitor
in lieu of a console streaming video
would be a great pillar of support for
this little device your only video
options at the moment include
crunchyroll crackle and sony's video
unlimited service if you're transferring
an existing Vita content to the
PlayStation TV then you're more than
likely to find games that don't work if
however you're starting from scratch
sony has built a special version of the
PlayStation Network store for
PlayStation TV that only displays
supported content using remote play with
the PlayStation 4 is a big selling point
for the PlayStation TV that will no
doubt entice a lot of PlayStation 4
owners the promise of being able to play
games in one room while your PlayStation
4 is and another sounds great but for
one reason or another be it sony's video
compression methodology or network
limitations there's always a noticeable
amount of latency to contend with
it doesn't matter if you're
communicating over a wireless network or
plugged right into the router remote
play works but there's noticeable lag
and latency issues that will make it
unfeasible to play competitive games at
a competitive level unfortunately we can
only recommend remote play via the
PlayStation TV for slower paced games
that don't require twitch precision
the PlayStation TV has a lot of
potential but it's obvious that Sony
still has a lot of work to do remote
play is only viable for some types of
games and there are plenty of games that
should work from the Vita PSP and ps1
libraries that are inexplicably
unsupported at least the games that are
natively supported do play really well
with the exception of some video games
that use the PlayStation TV's emulated
touch controls which are pretty
cumbersome in practice lastly so needs
to make sure that video apps such as
Netflix actually work because there's no
technical reason why they shouldn't at
this point it feels like the PlayStation
TV came out too soon and its software
could have benefited from a few extra
months of development